so you mentioned that moja is a superset
of python
can you run
python code
as if it's Mojo code
yes yes
so and so and this has two sides of it
so Mojo's not done yet so I'll give you
a disclaimer mode it's not done yet but
already we see people that take small
pieces of python code move it over they
don't change it and you can get 12x
speed UPS like somebody's just tweeting
about that yesterday which is pretty
cool right and again interpreters
compilers right and so without changing
any code without also this is not with
this is not jit compiling or do any
anything fancy this is just basic stuff
moving straight over now Mojo will
continue to grow out and as it grows out
it will have more and more and more
features and our North Stars to be a
full super set of python and so you can
bring over
basically arbitrary python code and have
it just work and it may not always be
12x faster but um but it should be at
least as fast and way faster in many
cases this is the goal right
um
now I'll take time to do that and python
is a complicated language there's not
just the obvious things but there's also
non-obvious things that are complicated
like we have to be able to talk to C
python packages to talk to the C API and
there's a bunch of there's a bunch of
pieces so you have to I mean just to
make explicit the obvious that may not
be so obvious until you think about it
so you know to run python code that
means you have to run all the python
packages and libraries yeah yeah so that
means what what's the relationship
between Mojo and C python the The
Interpreter that's
presumably would be tasked with getting
those packages to work yep so in the
fullness of time Mojo will solve for all
the problems and you'll be able to move
python packages over and run them in
Mojo without the C python without C
python someday yeah right it's not today
but someday and that'll be a beautiful
day because then you'll get a whole
bunch of advantages and you'll get
massive speed ups and things like this
but you can do that one at a time right
you can move packages one exactly but
but we're not willing to wait for that
python is too important the ecosystem is
too broad we want to both be able to
build Mojo out we also want to do it the
right way without time like in without
intense time pressure we're obviously
moving fast but
um and so what we do is we say okay well
let's make it so you can import an
arbitrary existing package
arbitrary
including like you write your own on
your local disk or whatever it's not
it's not like a standard like an
arbitrary package
and import that using C python because C
python already runs all the packages
right and so what we do is we built an
integration layer where we can actually
use C python again I'm practical and to
actually just load and use all the
existing packages as they are the
downside of that is you don't get the
benefits of Mojo for those packages
right and so they'll run as fast as they
do in the traditional C python way
but what that does is that gives you an
incremental migration path and so if you
say hey cool well here's a you know the
python ecosystem is vast I want all of
it to just work but there's certain
things that are really important and so
if I if I'm doing weather forecasting or
something well
I want to be able to load all the data I
want to be able to work with it and then
I have my own crazy algorithm inside of
it Well normally I'd write that in C
plus plus
if I can write in Mojo and have one
system that scales well that's way
easier to work with is it hard to do
that to to have that layer
that's running C python because is there
some communication back and forth yes
it's complicated I mean this is what we
do so I mean we make it look easy but um
it is it is complicated but what we do
is we use
the C python existing interpreter so
it's running its own byte codes and
that's how it provides full
compatibility and then it gives us C
python objects and we use those objects
as is and so that way we're fully
compatible with all the C python objects
and all the the you know it's not just
the python part it's also the C packages
the C libraries underneath them because
they're often hybrid and so we can fully
run and we're fully compatible with all
that and the way we do that is that we
have to play by the rules right so we we
keep objects in that representation when
they're coming from that world what's
the representation that's being used in
memory you'd have to know a lot about
how the C python interpreter works it
has for example reference counting but
also different rules on how to pass
pointers around and things like this
super low level fiddly and it's not like
python it's like how The Interpreter
works okay and so that gets all exposed
out and then you have to Define wrappers
around the low level C code right and so
what this means is you have to know not
only C
which is a different role from python
obviously not only python but the
rappers but The Interpreter and the
rappers and the implementation details
and the conventions and it's just this
really complicated mess and when you do
that now suddenly you have a debugger
that debugs python they can't step into
C code
right so you have this two world problem
right and so by pulling this all into
Mojo what you get is you get one world
you get the ability to say cool I have
untyped very Dynamic beautiful simple
code
okay I care about performance for
whatever reason right there's lots of
reasons you could you you might care and
so then you add types you can
parallelize things you can vectorize
things you can use these techniques
which are General techniques to solve a
problem and then you can do that by
staying in the system and if you're uh
you have that that one python package
that's really important to you you can
move it to Mojo you get massive
performance benefits on that and other
other advantages you know if you like
stack types it's nice if they're
enforced some people like that right
rather than being hints so there's other
advantages too and then
um
and then you can do that incrementally
as you go
so one different perspective on this
would be
um
why Mojo instead of making C python
faster or redesigning C python yeah well
I mean you can argue Mojo is redesigning
see python but but uh but why not make
see python faster and better and other
things like that there's lots of people
working on that so actually there's a
team at Microsoft that is really
improving I think see python
3.11 came out in October or something
like that and it was you know 15 faster
20 faster across the board which is
pretty huge given how mature python is
and things like this and so
um that's awesome I love it
um
doesn't run on GPU it doesn't do AI
stuff like it doesn't do vectors doesn't
do things I'm 20 is good 35 000 times is
better right so like they're they're
they're definitely I'm a huge fan of
that work by the way and it composes
well with what we're doing and so it's
not it's not like we're fighting or
anything like that it's actually just
general it's goodness for the world but
it's just a different path right and
again we're not working forwards from
making python a little bit better we're
working backwards from what is the
limited physics what's the process of uh
supporting python code to Mojo is there
um
what's involved in that in the process
is there tooling for that not yet so um
we're missing some basic features right
now and so we're continuing to drop out
new features like on a weekly basis but
um you know at the fullness of time give
us a year and a half maybe two years is
it an automatable process so when we're
ready it'll be very automatable yes is
it automatable automate like is it
possible to automate
in the general case the python Mojo
conversion yeah well you're saying it's
possible well so and this is why I mean
among other reasons why we use tabs yes
right so first of all by being a
superset yep you could it's like C
versus C plus plus can you move C code
to C plus plus
yes yeah right and you move you you can
move C code to C plus plus and uh then
you can adopt classes you can add adopt
templates you can adopt other references
or whatever C plus features you want
after you move C to C code to C plus
plus like you can't use templates in C
right and so if you leave it a c fine
you can't use the cool features but it
still works right and C and C plus plus
code work together and so that's the
analogy right now
um here right you you you
there there's not a python is bad and
the Mojo is good right Mojo just gives
you super powers right and so if you
want to stay with python that's cool uh
but the tooling should be actually very
beautiful and simple because we're doing
the hard work of defining a superset
right so you're right so there's several
things to say there but also the
conversion tooling should probably give
you hints as to like how you can improve
the code and then yeah exactly once
you're in the new world then you can
build all kinds of cool tools to say
like hey should you adopt this feature
or like and we haven't built those tools
yet but I fully expect those tools will
exist and you can like you know
modernize your code or however you want
to look at it right so I mean one of the
things that I think is really
interesting about Mojo is that there
have been a lot of projects to improve
python over the years
um everything from you know getting
python run on the Java virtual machine
uh Pi Pi which is the jit compiler
there's tons of these projects out there
that have been working on improving
python in various ways
they founded one or two camps so Pipi is
a great example of a camp that is trying
to be compatible with python
even there not really it doesn't work
with all the C packages and stuff like
that but um but they're trying to be
compatible with python there's also
another category of these things where
they're saying well python is too
complicated
and you know I'm gonna cheat on the
edges and it you know like integers in
Python can be an arbitrary size integer
if you care about it fitting in a going
fast on a register and a computer that's
really annoying right and so you can you
can choose to pass on that right you can
say well people don't really use big
integers that often therefore I'm going
to just not do it and it'll be fine
not not a python superset or you can do
the heart thing and say okay this is
python
you can't be a super set of python
without
being a super set of python and that's a
really hard technical problem but it's
in my opinion worth it right and it's
worth it because it's not about any One
packages about this ecosystem it's about
what python means for the world and it
also means we don't want to repeat the
python 2 to Python 3 transition like we
want we want people to be able to adopt
this stuff quickly and so by doing that
work we can help lift people yeah the
challenge it's really interesting
technical philosophical challenge of
really making a language a superset of
another language
that's breaking my brain a little bit
well it paints you in the corners so um
again I'm very happy with python right
so joking all joking aside I think that
the indentation thing is not the actual
important part of the problem yes right
but the the fact that python has amazing
Dynamic meta programming features and
they translate to beautiful static meta
programming features I think is profound
I think that's huge right and so python
I've talked with Guido about this it's
it's like it was not designed to do what
we're doing that was not the reason they
built it this way but because they
really cared and they were very
thoughtful about how they designed the
language it scales very elegantly in the
space but if you look at other languages
for example CNC plus plus
right if you're building a superset you
get stuck with the design decisions of
the subset
right and so you know C plus plus is way
more complicated because of C in the
Legacy than it would have been if they
would have theoretically designed a from
scratch thing
and there's lots of people right now
that are trying to make C plus plus
better and recent tax C plus plus it's
gonna be great we'll just change all the
syntax
but if you do that now suddenly you have
zero packages
so you don't have compatibility so what
what are the if you could just uh Linger
on that what are the
biggest challenges of keeping that
superset status
what are the things you're struggling
with is it all boil down to having a big
integer
no I mean it's it's one of the other
things usually it's the um it's a long
tail weird things so let me give you a
war story okay so War story in the space
is um you go way back in time project I
worked on is called clang
clang what it is it's a C C plus plus
parser right and when I started working
on clang
spent like 2006 or something is my 2007
2006 when I first started working on it
right
um it's funny how time flies uh yeah the
uh uh I started that project and I'm
like okay well I want to build a c
parser C plus plus parser for lvm it's
gonna be the work GCC is yucky you know
this is mean earlier times it's yucky
it's on principled it has all these
weird features like all these bugs like
it's yucky so I'm going to build a
standard compliance CNC plus parser it's
gonna be beautiful it'll be amazing well
engineered all the cool things an
engineer wants to do
and so I started implementing building
it out and building it on building it
out and then I got to include
standardio.h
and all of the headers in the world use
all the GCC stuff
okay this is in so again come back away
from
Theory back to reality right I had I was
in a fork on the road I could have built
an amazingly beautiful academic thing
that nobody would ever use
or I could say well it's yucky in
various ways all these design mistakes
accents of History the Legacy at that
point GCC was like over 20 years old
which by the way yeah now lvm's over 20
years old
yeah time catches up to you right and so
um you you say okay well what what is
easier right I mean as an engineer it's
it's actually much easier for me to go
Implement long tail compatibility weird
features even if they're distasteful and
just do the hard work and like figure it
out reverse engineer understand what it
is write a bunch of test cases like try
to understand Behavior
it's way easier to do all that work as
an engineer than it is to go talk to all
C programmers and get argue with them
and try to get them to rewrite their
code yeah
right and because that breaks a lot more
things yeah and and you have realities
like nobody actually even understands
how the code works because it was
written by the person who quit 10 years
ago right and so this is this software
has kind of frustrating that way but
it's that's how the world works right
yeah unfortunately you can never be this
perfect beautiful thing well there there
are occasions in which you get to build
like you know you invent a new
data structure or something like that or
there's this beautiful algorithm that
just like makes you super happy right I
I love that moment but but when you're
working with people yeah and you're
working with code and Dusty deck code
bases and things like this right it's
not about what's theoretically beautiful
it's about what's practical what's real
what people will actually use and I
don't meet a lot of people that say I
want to rewrite all my code
just for the sake of it
by the way there could be interesting
possibilities and we'll probably talk
about it where AI can help rewrite some
code that might be
farther out feature but it's a really
interesting one how that could create
more
be a a tool in the battle against this
monster of complexity that you mentioned
yeah